all that buddy buddy stuff you have got
to fight that dude and there's a nerd
video there's story there he's gonna
sell tickets you're both gonna make more
money than God to set up your family
it's a sport we want to say it's a sport
but then it is a cage fight all
right was it cage fighters a sport to
the sport the Kelsey Brothers don't have
a problem beating each other it is what
it is it's a sport so I think we got to
look at this like a sport especially
marab is a business standpoint nobody's
offering the fight so you coming out
right after you wanna go um I would
never fight Al Jermaine well dude you
just yourself wait to even get the
offer because right now we're trying to
figure out there's a lot of hype around
them but him squashing that kind of
takes the win out of our sails wait till
you get the official offer to make a
comment on it nobody's even talking
about that right now aljo has to fight
so who don't do for mirabi you know if
he doesn't want to fight Al Joe this is
also assuming that aljo beat sahuda
which is a big if but marab so who knows
the fight